Jen it just seems to me that chess in
America for girls and for women has
gotten a lot better like it in less ten
years talk about the development for a
sec yeah it's really incredible as
somebody who's been involved in women
empowerment ever since I wrote my books
I chest [ __ ] and play like a girl I I
really feel like there's so much
momentum right now for girls in chat
exactly and it's really beautiful to see
like you've been pushing pushing pushing
and now it's here and I'm talking both
the top level as we see girls like her
so yep and Jennifer you Annie Wang
accomplishing so many things not just
that the girls level but at the adult
level right I'm Jennifer you even
winning a medal at the Olympiad for the
US team exactly and then we also have at
the outrage level we talked about
scouting and we had a big event today
for scouting and the girls are able to
earn the merit badge for scouts now for
the first time and you also look at the
statistics at US chess we have more
girls of women playing than ever and
it's going up slowly yet could be faster
but the point is it keeps growing right
and you also see that there's a lot of
different tournaments flourishing we've
got the National girls Tournament of
Champions every year that's in
conjunction with the US Open that's like
the top girl from every state exactly
and that's a great event there's a 5k
prize for first and then there's the
last it's also girls are getting
scholastics program scholarships sorry
that's right and you know you also have
the u.s. girls junior championship which
actually takes place every year here in
st. Louis alongside with the Junior
Championship the Open
exactly and then there's also the
all-girls Nationals so there's just like
so many opportunities for girls to shine
I mean I should point out that they also
play a mix tournament so it's not like
they're always playing young girls
comedy right hands but the nice thing
about these girls competitions is it
often there's money and scholarships at
stake so it gives them a chance to kind
of pursue children on a more serious
level and it's really beautiful to see
another great shining light of US chess
women is a Rachel Lee yeah yeah
eight-year-old Nienow nemesis of
johner sure as you oh okay she really is
a big favorite here in the st. Louis
chess club she came once for ultimate
moves and she was on a team with Rex
actually yep and she played against John
Herschel found some brilliant moves I
think Garry Kasparov was on Rachael's
team as well it was like cheering her on
we were we were there for that that was
fun
she keeps finding the right moves girl
and being only nine years old she was
actually recently the top eight-year-old
in the whole country boy or girl which
is a really fantastic trend she and
Alice Lee another another shiny light of
us chess is they actually both became
experts at the age of eight which
smashed previous records by quite a
while and probably like almost a year
and get this they did it within a week
of each other how's that for
synchronicity whoa well that's just a
competition pushing pushing them harder
exactly that's what you see you see when
you have two girls who are eight or nine
and so strong they push each other
we've got charissa yep you go work T
you've got all these talented girls and
it just kind of builds upon itself
that's what I'm seeing in the US Women's
Championship is a younger each year it
seems like the age goes down even though
we do have arena crush and anisette on
ski two players who we would consider
veterans who have been playing in the
chariot tournaments for decades
they're still there but the strength of
the younger players is increasing I'm
gonna say dramatically because it feels
that way to me I think it's because
first of all there's these great
conditions and prizes here at the
championships I know these girls dream
about coming here because it's not just
I'm winning the win it's also a lot of
fun okay I'll tell you I mean these
girls always really enjoy themselves
here in st. Louis they stay at a nice
hotel they have fun in between the games
and this isn't just for girls
all kids love chess they're not just
there to win they're also there to have
fun they can go hand in hand
yeah they hope so yeah yeah losing isn't
that much fun but I understand what
you're saying exactly the trips it's
almost like a vacation right so I think
that's part of it that there's just so
many more opportunities like a chassés
may come more popular in America so
girls see that this is not just a way to
get into college this is also a way just
to succeed a period I remember when I
was coming up in chess Irina and I it
was I were driving one another yeah in
your careers that's right I Irina and I
often travel to events but like I always
was both good friends with her but also
competitive like I knew that if I was
gonna win a championship I had to beat
her exactly so that raised the bar and
that's what we're seeing now the bar
just keeps getting raised and I'm
actually getting more involved in US
chess and our Women's Initiative and the
director of that now and to me it's like
really exciting to see how far we can
push it because I think more than ever
people in the mainstream are realizing
games like chess are so important for
girls because it's a way to build stem
you know to give STEM careers and make
girls understand that even if you're the
only one or even if you're outnumbered
this is almost an opportunity it's not a
curse that you're one of the only is
actually an opportunity because you we
need your perspective we need that
diversity to make the sport better but
then again being a critic supreme that I
am the we're doing marvelous
scholastically were drawing girls women
into the game but we're not giving them
opportunities to be professionals we
could do more for that and that's that's
a little bit where the Karen's Cup comes
in that now in addition to the US
women's championship with 100k prize
fund we've got an additional event on
the calendar for worldwide but you know
certainly some US players can dream of
making that we have to this year mm-hmm
but yeah you're right I mean I think
there's a lot more that can be done I
mean hey if I was a marketing director I
would look at some of these incredible
girls in chess who were you know you
know just really representing us on an
international stage so beautifully and I
would try to sponsor that right come on
look at these girls I know
Annie Wang Jennifer you receive yes
Rachel yeah and some of the older ones
as well the adults like you
people like Tata and Irina and Sabina
exactly they're just like such cool
people right and also doing really well
in competing in a male-dominated field
III have a sponsorship with PokerStars
but I really feel like there could be
boar I know that Tania who's here with
us actually at the Karen's cup doing
commentary has some sponsorships with
Red Bull which by the way is also Hikaru
Nakamura sponsor indeed but yeah I
really think that the marketing
directors need to like wake up and say
like hey these ladies are steel exactly
well I still recall is it was talked
about having fun of the US Championship
for me I got this opportunity to play
some bug house with some of the ladies
of playing in the US Championship right
well Maggie and I were making and I were
a team together we were playing Carissa
stuff and I was having a lot of fun in
fact I was having so much fun
Rex came over and said can i play I
didn't say no I didn't
I said I'm Rex's coach but we haven't
gotten the bunkhouse yeah so that's a
problem it's funny that you mention
Maggie Feng because she's actually she
was a personal woman first girl rather
to win the national junior high school
championship right so you what I was
thinking and this was for overall it was
yes and that's why I think it's like
such an easy like thing to kind of
promote girls in chess because a its
women's empowerment girls empowerment
but also it's one of the only sports
where girls and boys can both play on
the same table
mm-hmm so yes we have lots of great
girls Championships and those are super
fun girls make friends but also a Maggie
Feng can go in and just beat all the
boys exactly so it's it's really a
beautiful thing that in chess we have
this ability to play any gender any age
on the same board but are we gonna see
more professional women players yes I
think so you are you think so
I mean because I'm I did yeah I mean I
was this team captain and I was just
shocked how
little opportunities they were were for
professional adult women and that was a
few years ago and now I think there's
there's more opportunities you see some
of these protests league teams getting
more support and there's incentives to
get women into those teams right you
know st. Louis always does brilliantly
picking their squads for the
archbishop's and of course the Karen's
Cup and I think with the new leadership
in fidei I really believe we're gonna
see more opportunities I mean I guess
I'm you know how I am I'm always
optimistic
whatever is perpetually optimistic that
you have to be exactly